stunning I was like oh [ __ ] and he just
walks up to her he goes you have the
most beautiful eyes I've ever seen right
and she just goes okay he goes hi and he
gets too sad when she walks away and I
died laughing cuz I was like bro what
the [ __ ] was that just get your [ __ ]
sandwich and go but he would do that
multiple times right and then it would
work so it's not like his approach was
wrong it's just that that was just the
probability of that maybe it wasn't the
setting maybe she wasn't feelin him but
I started to realize like watching him
and how he would go in without doubting
himself
and I think that was a thing that would
just grab girl's attention right his
approach was totally wrong mm-hmm 100%
raw high he was getting away with was
the fact that he didn't give all thought
and he would go to the next person but
if I told him and you know I'm being
very dramatic right now but I'm like yo
your mom is going to die if you don't if
you don't out of the three girls you
don't get this girl he would change his
approach the fact that he was confident
was like I use I kind of nailed it
before he said it he didn't care if he
got rejected yeah but to compliment a
girl on her beauty is my biggest pet
peeve ever mmm
you don't compliment a girl on their
beauty when you approach her you
compliment her on something that she had
to work for therefore she's gonna go out
she took 20 minutes to think about what
high heels do I want to wear what dress
do I want to wear so if you go yeah I
got it I got to tell you I'm here with
my buddy David I appreciate your fashion
like that's relation I'm good like you
know the sandwich that you made she's
like okay where do I suck your dick a
single man told me that my turkey
sandwich game was like whatever the girl
had to work for she would appreciate
that a lot more therefore I'm gonna make
another analogy a lot of guys that I
coach um I was about to say the famous
people but like they're they're like
father and mother really big actors they
never had to work
the money so they were given that so
they don't appreciate that rather people
that have to do a podcast for ten would
you know do all this stuff when they get
that money you worked for it you
appreciate that a lot more same thing
for women know if they had to work for
something you say appreciate your
fashion you have good energy that that
is the way to go that's good to know
because I feel like that's like the
standard thing to do right oh let me go
compliment her on how pretty she is are
all that type of stuff yeah because I
think if I if I look back and I say when
I was mmm I say you know young age you
know 18 and younger right I I think I
was always scared of because of how
unconfident I was about my approach
because I didn't want to come off as
creepy anymore I feel like that's the
death word for guys if a girl calls you
a creep it's like almost calling us like
a rapist I wanna I wanna [ __ ] cuz I I
want to remember too that you know this
approach of me just like not caring so
much took time right because you know
high school David was not this way you
know high school David had one girl that
he wanted and then when I got her it
reminds me of your situation
right so when I when I received I did
that where I made her seem perfect so
when she left me I mentioned it on the
podcast when she left me I felt that my
value was in her so if Shaw you know
right have you said there and so I lost
value of myself so when she was like
David I don't want to be with you
anymore because then I was like oh I
don't have meaning because my meaning
you and so that was like the biggest it
took me like I say two years to get over
and those two years of my life was some
of the worst moments of my life because
I didn't understand how my value and so
she was the biggest blessing in disguise
because because I experienced that I was
like wait a second
you're a [ __ ] loser why don't you
value yourself first before you go ahead
and try to seek that as somebody else
and I had this moment and it's muhfucka
so there was a point where I had a she
she ended up being with somebody else
that was trying to get with her while we
were together oh right
and that [ __ ] devastated me because that
[ __ ] was a loser okay so I was
like out of all the people you could
have gotten why this cuz he was a loser
and you got with him that makes me dirt
ground and I'm gonna going through a
depression for two years go [ __ ]
yourself that's what it made me feel
like and I was so [ __ ] torn about
that [ __ ] but I remembered there was a
moment where she and I I desperately was
trying to get her back right for the
next year and a half cuz we were best
friends before we got together
and so at this moment I just because I
remember this day like it was yesterday
it was I I was taking her to Community
College after I left
UCR I went to Community College and then
she was there too
so we live close to each other and I
wanted to develop this friendship
getting after we broke up and I would
take her to and to class because I
wanted to get close to her right again
she wasn't interested in me but she
looked at me one day and she goes you
know you're really kind of kind of
annoying and I stop for a second and I
when I looked at I was like annoying and
I thought she made me mad and I was like
what do you mean I know you're kind of
obnoxious and I remember when she said
that I was mad because what she said was
true it it wasn't because she said
something rude is because what she said
was true I was begging for this girl's
attention so [ __ ] hard there was so
obnoxious and at that I remember that
moment so well because I was like David
you are not gonna be that guy anymore
take a look at yourself what the [ __ ]
are you doing man and so when they broke
up I remember this moment so well she
came to my house and she was like hey so
I broke up with him and I looked at her
I was like that's cool why are you
telling me right and she goes well like
you know I just you know we're just not
working out anymore so I you know like I
just wanted somebody to come to and I
was like he came to the wrong door I was
like why are you here and then I kind of
like I could tell it irritated her a
little bit and I was is so interesting
where I had that moment and I was like
I've been playing this whole thing wrong
you know what I mean like I thought once
again that me being the agreeable guy
taking her to school doing all the stuff
trying to be the important person in her
life was gonna create value and it
didn't and that was the turning point
for me where I was like you know what
dude you're doing this [ __ ] all were
how did you realize you're doing it
wrong like that I feel like that's very
impressive like I like how did you do
that I think it's just you know I talked
about that personality of